I'm back home up here in Scotland in
Greenock when my grandfather who's have
a butcher shop and I'm here to see if
he's still there when my grandfather
came back from the war 1945 he opened a
butcher's on green it's bustling high
street in those days everyone brought
their meat from the local butcher and
their queues outside the shop and it
wasn't just like that in greener when I
was a kid everyone brought their meat
from local butchers like my
grandfather's but Britain's butchers are
beginning to look like an endangered
species where'd you get you mean from
Tesco's
supermarkets and what's wrong will you
butchers
I found it now called to these
photographs this is where my
grandfather's butcher shop used to be
and it's actually a sort of health food
shop now which is my sad in a way
because all I remember from him in the
early days is just how long and hard he
used to work that's why this used to be
that showed yesterday us these days 75%
of our media's bought from supermarkets
and sadly butchers shops are closing
across the UK and it's not just the lack
of customers that threatens our high
street butchers they're also struggling
to find people who want to work in them
ever thought about becoming a butcher
consider becoming a butcher you leave
your school look over your son yeah
every thought about becoming a butcher
if we lose the high street butcher we
lose a crucial food skill the average
age of a British butcher today is 57
years of age so if there's any chance of
the high street butchers surviving we've
got to encourage more youngsters to come
into the industry I'm here in Lee's at
the Thomas Denby college to see if it's
a glimmer of hope all right guys
these three seventeen year old lads are
bucking the trend and training to be
skilled butchers and one of the few
colleges that still offer a butchery
course what's your ambitions I like to
take over my father's shop he's got a
shop in the borough market women like
butchers although it's fireman butchers
what's a butcher's of the new fireman
right a local butcher they love a good
butcher
if these dads are gonna succeed they
need to know how to cut knees but they
also need to understand how to cook it
okay cooking the steak and it's a big
advantage with customers walk in and ask
you how to cook a steak perfectly
I've got a fail-safe trick to make sure
your steak is cooked perfectly every
time
so we got rare medium well-done legit
there is that like yeah yeah that is a
rare steak tell me how you cooked yours
medium good man so touch it how's that
cuz kill [ __ ] oh yeah that is well
done yeah looks like a pair of dr.
Martens and you cook this big girlfriend
two weeks ago yeah they should still
with you yeah is she still chewing as
well
give these guys a chance and support
your local butchers these guys are here
to stay and we need more of them it's
almost like sort of rewinding giving
birth now you're putting it back in once
it's been born